what's going on guys
WWE it is the road to Wrestlemania which
is happening this Sunday WrestleMania 31
we just received the opportunity to go
down and talk to some of the WWE's top
superstars so we decided to send our top
field reporter our only field reporter
mr. Nick Mundy so what are you gonna do
you're gonna stick around and let screen
junkies in the WWE run wild on you
brother
hey this is Nick Monday with screen
junkies and I'm here to interview
two-time WWE Champion diva champion
Paige how's it going that was probably
the worst introduction I've ever had
been hey this a screw jockeys it's Nick
Mundy with Seth Rollins probably the one
one of the best wrestlers in the WWE
right sir that's really the introduction
I get hey screen junkies I'm with Daniel
Bryan the best wrestler ever seriously
this guy is amazing it's just a huge
honor to meet you sir like thank you so
much oh yeah thank you that's a great
introduction thank you it's nice to get
a compliment
I'm with Xavier woods of the new day new
day new day new tank see there's power
in that new day you just move on okay
okay okay hey screen junkies I'm with
Dolph Ziggler the zig zag man the zig
ster dinkenstein himself Dolph Ziggler a
good guy and a super hero in his own
right I don't think I'm that good of a
guy I mean I think a good guy would
predator handshake me you're a good guy
I just know movie references which by
the way you know chicks dig no no they
don't
I'm with Zack Ryder WWE Superstar and
all-around good dude love that champion
you forgot to mention that
that's right he is the Internet champion
uh we have an Internet show screen
junkies and then all the time actually
honest trailers all that stuff yeah do
you see ever see myself who who are you
I'm just kidding of course yeah oh thank
you man this is great guys this
interviews going good so far Wow
oh now you got Russell you got
WrestleMania coming up this week are you
excited yep
and you started early right you started
when you were I stopped on us that Dean
yeah when I was 13 um I was just reading
Star Wars Expanded Universe books and
trying to convince my mom at mono so yes
that's really really sad why are you so
awesome I don't know that's not really
my cup of tea is like it's a perspective
thing you just said I was a handsome man
that's your perspective that you believe
I'm a handsome man yes I think you're a
handsome man too
it's all perspective because I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna do our secret
handshake yep yep not that's not really
a secret it's just a normal handshake
now my best friend Seth Rollins he's got
a big match coming up with Randy Orton
and you're also like as you said the
money in the bank winner can you tell
the audience the screen junkies audience
what that means well that means that I
have a contract that I can cash in from
now until June for a shot at the W World
Heavyweight Championship anytime
anyplace whenever I see fit yeah it's
exciting I see your eyes getting bigger
that's a very good thing right don't do
right now
well the champion isn't in the general
vicinity so no well let's go find the
chilis he's at and I'll distract him and
then you can you can pin them what's
what in the world makes you think that
Brock Lesnar's out of chile's right now
I'm just guessing I'm throwing things
out there he's maybe out of rouse let's
just go find them I'll distract him be
like hey dude what's up and then you
blindside them and then we'll do it
together
I feel like you're not gonna help me out
at all I might sacrifice you I'm fine
with that are you ready for the ladder
match at WrestleMania yeah you heard it
here folks he's ready to fight everyone
at WrestleMania and he's ready to kick
some butt now you're in that you're also
in WWE total divas right the reality TV
show very correct yes actually me and my
fiance we watch total divas together and
she's a quite avid fiance yeah why is it
like a like any kind of forest thing no
it's a little it's a little Jenny in
Forrest Gump well good for you buddy
I know right yeah I work for screen
junkies and we have a lot of movie fans
and superhero fans like that that's what
they're into so if you could tell them
why screen jockey fans should be
watching WrestleMania and WWE you know
if you like wrestling right this is
gonna be great but if you don't like
wrestling there's so many other things
to do with your time in this world on
this planet right like we could just be
doing our lives we could be outside
living experiencing the air getting in
the water like helping people so that
when we die they throw us at some sort
of national parade we're not just made
to entertain people we're here to live
oh yeah
July yes that's that's great that's
that's awesome now I've had a dream I've
been a WWE fan my whole life and I've
always wanted someone to like a
professional WWE superstar to cut a
promo on me I can give you some just
tidbits and you won't hurt my feelings
you won't hurt my feelings I peed the
bed when I was in fifth grade I didn't
talk till I was like six that makes
sense now it all adds up cuz here you
are a grown man and you can still barely
speak I know I probably still wet the
bed now at this age you letter you're
wearing two pens currently fair enough
sir uh I fear - they had depends for
your whole body because you're
perspiring at an excessive rate right
now warm and look at warm we've
established it it's not warm so we've
established that you need to be silent
you need to be a boy that you're stupid
that you sweat too much
you should wear depends for your whole
body and you need to shut up I think you
just cut a promo on me I didn't mean you
have like this good thing going what do
you mean like a Riggs Murtaugh like
Lethal Weapon I think you're a better
Riggs because you got the ponytail and
it was out well man there you go why are
you so wet I know I something everyone's
gonna ask that's strange it's really hot
well you're essentially realized
superhero you know yeah me you're you I
mean that's what's great about w w so it
no I know that's that's not the first
time someone's told me that well
predator high-five well just maybe just
a just a handshake okay like like a
couple dudes just a couple dudes me and
Brian Monday just hanging out this
couple dudes hang it out yeah okay we
won't do that here yeah yeah whatever
helps team Rollins yes high-five it did
it yeah gerrae
not in your face but just why no I'm not
not in your face I'm just not
your face I think it's just it's just
cool this friendship has blossomed yes
friendship yay thank you so much yeah
thank me I'm fired
wow that was super fun but you know we
like to keep it honest around here and I
gotta say your microphone work was very
poor yeah I'm not good at stuff and then
I got to meet everyone I got a little
nervous plus you guys should have
honestly knew what you're getting into
yeah this is kind of um you guys not
surprised no sorry it's okay buddy hey
if you want to see more of Nick's super
fun high jinks and shenanigans with WWE
Superstars click right here and let me
ask you what's the best movie to ever
star professional wrestler leave us an
answer in the comment section below
and the best answer we're gonna send you
a screen junkies t-shirt
I want to thank Nick Mundy I want to
thank screen junkies and the WWE for
continuing to make dreams come true
Thank You hell you got it buddy and I
want to thank you for watching I'm Hal
rod Nicky's Nick Monday hit us up on
Twitter bye bye why does Daniel Bryan
deserve be in the main event of
Wrestlemania make me appeal to the K ok
cell the people on listen dummies by the
pay-per-view this guy's awesome
just do it that was really good